Speaker 1: All right. It's time for the mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com if you
have something to say, it might be featured on
the show. Keep it polite, keep it substantive,
keep it productive. Yeah, only like 5% of people
do, but we have a lot of those 5% to be featured
today. Let's jump. Jump right into some of
these. Max wrote in and Max very, very upset,
says, Will you admit you were wrong about Russia?
Russia. Russia. David, you incredulously made fun
of Trump when he was talking about Russia. Russia.
Russia. You even pretended or purposely were
ignorant and said You don't even know what he's
talking about. Will you ever admit you were wrong
and Trump was right? Michael Sussman is on trial
for exactly what Trump was talking about. It turns
out the whole Russiagate scandal was generated by
the Hillary Clinton campaign personally approved
Hillary Clinton then surreptitiously fed to
the FBI. Will you ever acknowledge that you
that or will you continue to pretend like this
didn't happen? Well, in fact, I can't think of
anything in particular that I was wrong about
when it comes to Russia, Russia, Russia. Michael
Sussman was acquitted by a jury. Now people are
saying, oh, the jury wasn't a good jury. Well,
that's the process we have. And I mean, listen, I
never said Trump was going to be caught on video
plotting stuff with Putin. We were nuanced and
specific in terms of what what we thought went
on. And so I'll admit, I have no problem admitting
I was wrong about things when I'm wrong about the
max. Also writing. Also, when will you admit
that the Wuhan lab story is not only real,
but leftists and big tech censored us for years
for talking about it? And you have no problem
with that. Same with the Hunter Biden laptop
from Hell Story. Yep, I covered both stories.
We follow evidence and that's it. Max, I'm sorry.
You're sort of living in a fantasy world. Okay?
Jumpin Jack Flash wrote in and said, I watched
your rebroadcast of Trump's Wyoming speech. I
quickly learned from your narrative interruptions
during Trump's speech that you're quite a moronic
ahole. Good job. Perhaps your mother should have
aborted you. What a beautiful message of peace
and love and productivity. You know, when I get
a message like this, I really think to myself
I should reconsider my opinions and
political views, because this is so
it's just so respectfully written and it
just really makes you think introspectively,
could I be wrong? And so I am going to revisit
all of my political views thanks to this email.
Isn't that beautiful? Okay. Richard wrote in
Richard says that he joined Trump's platform Truth
Social, which Trump calls truth central.
Speaker 3: Truth Central.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Richard says. So, David,
I was jaw dropped for the first 3 minutes
after joining Troth. Essentially after that I
realized it's literally 90% trolls. It's a turd
spiraling the drain. Yeah, there's a lot of bot
like and sort of troll like activity on there.
And I joined sort of like as an experiment,
you know, I'm not really expecting any kind of
major dialog or anything like that there, but
I encourage others just to check it out. And
the replies to the things I post are extremely
nuts. Very, very nuts. It could survive. I mean,
listen, they quite literally cloned Twitter.
The website is just a copy of Twitter.
And so to the extent that Twitter is successful,
at least truth through social, now I'm saying
it truth central, at least truth social is
starting with like a layout, a user experience
that kind of makes sense. But I don't know if
you told me a year from now Truth Social will
be huge. I'd be like, Yeah, maybe if you told me
a year from now Truth Social will be shut down,
I'd say, yeah, that that's plausible
too. Justin wrote in about gun control
Justin from Dallas or J.R. from Dallas. As he goes
by, says David, relatively new listener would love
to hear your thoughts on the debate technique that
gun rights folks use when debating gun control of
assault weapons. They tend to start lecturing the
gun control advocate on the technicalities of the
guns to show their supposedly informed knowledge.
It's ridiculous. How would you respond? Well,
yes, it's very popular when we start saying,
hey, look like assault style rifles keep being
used in mass shootings. There's a couple
approaches they'll take. One is they'll say
most gun deaths are from handguns. It's a yes.
That's true. That's a different problem. There's
really there's there's really three problems,
actually, when it comes to gun violence
or gun deaths. I should better say it's death
by suicide with a gun, what we might call
one off gun homicides, which includes one
or two victims. Remember, it's only a mass
shooting when it goes beyond that, either
to three or four victims, depending on which
statistics you look at. So then you've got you're
sort of like a handgun, typically handgun based
incidents, which are one or. To victims. And then
you've got your mass shooting. So one technique is
they'll say more people die from handguns. What
are you going to ban? Handguns. It's like, well,
no, we're we're proposing different things when
it comes to the assault rifles, semi-automatics,
large capacity magazines, etc.. We want age
limits. We want, you know, all all these different
things separately. Let's talk about the handgun
piece as well. So one important thing is to say
we have many issues with firearms and we
have different solutions for each of them.
Then they'll get into what is an assault style
rifle. Anyway, I can change the appearance of
this firearm and make it not an assault rifle,
but it's still sort of the same firearm. Or
I can show you a firearm that looks different,
but still technically is an assault rifle.
What we have to do is just kind of zoom out and
go, okay, but hold on a second. The same type of
firearm continues to be used in mass shootings.
Frequently, whether I can identify every example
of it doesn't really matter. We can have informed
opinions about military conflict without knowing
every last detail about military strategy or tanks
or whatever the case may be. And it's really sort
of a red herring to avoid talking about the most
important thing. So you've got it. You've got to
take control. Back of the situation, I
think is the point I'm trying to make.
AJ wrote in about the night before the January
six insurrection, and AJ said, David, Sir Marjorie
Taylor GREENE has the same shoes as the person
of interest in the DC pipe bombing suspect the
night before the January 6th insurrection. What
do you think, David? Is it just a coincidence?
Dozens of people have written to me about this
and they've said we have no suspect for the pipe
bombing. Yep. The gate of the individual sort of
seems like it could be Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
It seems like it could be a woman rather than a
man. These are the I don't know if that's true.
People people write to me. And then most recently,
the shoes worn in the surveillance video by the
pipe bomber. Our shoes that Marjorie Taylor
GREENE also owns. Listen, everybody's right
about all those things. Big picture. I agree with
all those things. It sort of looks like it could
be Marjorie Taylor GREENE gate. It is. These are
the shoes that Marjorie Taylor GREENE has been
seen wearing. We don't have a set. It's all true.
It's completely circumstantial. It's completely
speculative. It is truly starting to get strange
that there's still no suspect for the D.C. pipe
bombing attempt from January 5th into January
6th. I don't know what to think about it. Could
it be Marjorie Taylor GREENE? At this point, I
can't rule it out, but it is very speculative
and it should be investigated for sure. Stephanie
wrote in and says, Thanks for the membership sale,
David. Sir, because of your irresponsibly
cheap Memorial Day sale, I have finally been
able to buy a membership to The David Pakman
Show I've been wanting to do for a while,
but couldn't quite find the funds. Sometimes sales
are not as amazing as they're made out to be,
but this really was a great discount and it made
my membership possible. Super excited to be on
board and to be putting my money where my mind
is. Keep it up. Your work is so needed. Thank you,
Stephanie. You know, I spoke on a livestream last
week. I was genuinely bummed out. I got about
two dozen emails when my paternity leave started
saying things like David, I just signed up and now
you're on paternity leave, cancel my membership
or I didn't know I was going to be paying for
repeats. Or you think you can just abandon
your audience and keep my YouTube subscription,
you're out of your mind. And I was so bummed out
because it's like, guys, aren't we progressive?
Aren't we in favor of paid paternity leave? That
doesn't mean you have to fund my paternity leave,
but like I am self-employed at the end of the day.
Right. Where do you think the money comes from?
And in particular from the people that don't even
pay the show is free. Like there's a little bit
of entitlement in saying, how dare I take time
off from something you get literally for free.
You don't pay anything for the show. So I
love that a bunch of people like Stephanie
and others later got in touch and said, David,
I apologize on behalf of those people. Those
are not real progressives. Real progressives would
understand what's going on here on the importance
of paternity leave. But it was it was a little
bit of a of of a bum out moment like and also I
said this on my recent live stream, too. This is
kind of why the right wins, because they you know,
the example I gave was you've got all
these right wingers who fund Charlie Kirk.
You think they're watching his show or counting
his days off or whatever? No, they just go. This
guy is saying the things, the types of things that
we want said. So we're just going to fund it and
that's it. And this is one of the real differences
between left and right. And we've experienced it
on the show many, many times before the right
gets. You've got to just fund this stuff and
let it exist because you think it should exist.
And, you know, counting days off or talking about
repeats, it's a little bit concerning. All right.
There's there's my rant. I'm off the soapbox.
Tom wrote in about LGBT nomenclature, and Tom
says, this is a semantics correction suggestion.
I think there is this is Tom writing. I
think there's a push to revert to the initial
LGBT instead of LGBTQ or LGBTQ, plus to stop
the disgruntled sides of people thinking,
Oh, LGBTQ, ABCD. It's just too much. People
that I know personally that are active in the
community always say LGBT. For this reason,
I have never changed. To be perfectly frank,
I've been saying LGBT from the start. I don't
think I ever used LGBT plus or LGBTQ. I have no
desire to exclude anyone from any group with which
they identify. But I. I am. It's interesting. It
hasn't even occurred to me to change the
word I use because I know that my audience
knows exactly the group I'm talking about, whether
or not I say LGBT or LGBTQ for queer people that
I just sort of I guess, you know, a more general
term. My my audience knows my views on this. My
audience knows my my inclusivity on this issue. So
I've just never felt the need. And quite frankly,
nobody's ever really corrected me that
I'm aware of. I mean, okay, I don't look
at YouTube comments, but I think people sort of
get the point of of of the language I use. But,
yes, I have noticed, I am just I am seeing a lot
of LGBT appearing again rather than the longer
ones. Listen, we're fighting for people's rights.
Let's get people rights. That's what I care about.
Ryan says masks are traumatizing, but RoboCop
guards are just fine. Yeah, this is a really
good commentary on the armed teachers
thing, Ryan says. Just wanted to point out
that forcing kids to wear. Masks would cause
irreparable damage to children's psyche.
Sure, it would save a few lives, but we
simply can't risk our kids well-being.
Oh, but let's go ahead and arm the teachers. Hire
an army of armed guards. Maybe even build a few
robo cops at the entrance of the schools. They'll
be fine with that, right? Yeah. And the point is,
one I've tweeted about previously, we couldn't
do masks in schools because it would just be
too traumatizing to the children. But it's
fine to arm teachers, send kids to school
with bulletproof backpacks and ballistic shield
blankets and all of these things. That's fine.
But the masks were just too much. It's crazy. It's
crazy. And lastly today from Julie, Julie says,
David, sir, I'm embarrassed and almost feel sorry
for the triggered projectionist Trumpists that
think they're trolling you. Most of us see
through their blatant failed attempts to own
the libs and might find it amusing if it weren't
so sad. You're obviously doing something right.
Keep up the tremendous work. Thank you, Julie.
Julie adds a piece. Please don't shave your head
when you hit the 2 million subscriber mark on
YouTube. Well, let's see if we can get me past
the 1.5 million subscriber mark first, and then
we'll figure out lesson if we got to 2 million. It
would be such a major milestone. I would consider
shaving my head. I don't know that anybody would
care about it, but I would consider doing info
at David Pakman dot com. Send me your thoughts.